welcome back to new rockstars I'm Aaron
Voss in the Incredible Hulk gave the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a big green
[ __ ] who's always angry and for that
alone it should not be overlooked sure
its lead was recast with our lovable
dummy who spoils everything and because
it's of a universal we can't really find
it on Disney Plus but as this [ __ ]
gets greener and greener the longer he's
in the blue Dungeon Mark 2 the second
part of this infinity saga rewatched
turned up a ton of Easter eggs some
obvious some less so like most of the
Avengers sneaked into this movie but
mostly this film establishes key rules
for the Hulk which have been a huge part
of why the MCU has been so successful so
let's break this movie down scene by
scene the opening titles rushed through
a prologue of the origin of Bruce Banner
played here by Edward Norton recast from
Eric Bana in the 2003 Angley Hulk film
we see Bruce to the lab chair green
gamma rays on his face a flashing danger
sign all of these visuals were recreated
from the 70s whole TV series intro among
the close ups of paperwork are a bunch
of Easter eggs the name Richard Rick
Jones appears in the comics Rick Jones
is a sidekick to Bruce Banner there's
also the name Leonard Samson a character
played by Ty Burrell in this film doc
Samson is another recurring character in
the whole comics in this movie is this
like hydrostan boyfriend ooh Bruce's ex
Betty Ross
rumors say Samson could return and
Falcon the Winter Soldier on Disney Plus
Betty Ross meanwhile Liv Tyler was
recast from Jennifer Connelly an Angley
film Connelly later came back in the MCU
as the voice of Karen the AI voice of
Peter Parker spider-man suit and
homecoming Nick Fury's name also appears
shield command Code Red and then there's
a quick shot of some Stark Industries
schematics of the sonic cannon the same
guy that they later used on Hulk in this
film Stark will install this same tech
and manager form in Brody's war machine
armor in Civil War and the same stark
tech also shows up on his drones used on
spider-man by Mysterio and far from home
and of course there's William Hurt as
general Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross future
Secretary of State and if there is a one
above all future Red Hulk yeah in the
comics Ross transforms himself into Red
Hulk and I have long believed that the
MCU is headed in that direction based on
a number of clues notice how in this
flashback Ross's hand is blood red here
well I guess hardly a smoking gun clue
but after a long absence in names you
the Russo brothers considered him
important enough to bring back in savour
some mysterious injury and
transformation five years ago I had a
heart attack I've dropped right in the
middle of my backswing turned out it was
the best round of my life because after
13 hours of surgery and a triple bypass
I found something 40 years in the Army
and never taught me perspective let's do
two keeps showing up for whatever reason
infinity war in game and hopefully
sometime later this year in Black Widow
a movie supposedly set between civil war
in infinity war yet Ross appears to be
de-age to look even younger than he
looks here in the Incredible Hulk we
discovered a possible aim Easter Egg and
Black Widow footage suggesting aldrich
killian explosive super soldier tech
from Iron Man 3 could be coming back the
same time Ross does in this movie Ross
seems super eager to build on the world
war 2 super soldier program and even
though the Fury's big weak tie and conic
confirmed they torched all the leftover
blood samples and Stern's lab who knows
what Ross could have gotten his hands on
first now originally this film was going
to open with an alternate scene in which
Banner tries to kill himself actually
the origin of that suicide attempt
referenced in The Avengers I put a
bullet in my mouth and the other guys
spit it out in this deleted scene Hulk
smashes polar ice causing a shock wave
that unearths if you look closely
Captain freakin America with the shield
gets just laying there in the ice like a
caveman corpse now we find roots in
Brazil meditating to control his
heartrate to prevent collateral damage
in one of the world's most densely
populated cities this movie is a reboot
but doesn't seem to pick up where the
angley Hulk left off it did end with
Eric Bana
Bruce somewhere in South America Bruce
watches on the TV the courtship of
eddie's father starring actor Bill Bixby
the actor who played dr. David Banner in
the Hulk seventies series and that show
his name was changed from Bruce to David
because according to Stan Lee and Lou
Ferrigno CBS thought the name Bruce
sounded too gay ish if only those 70s
CBS execs could see what Hulk lean has
been up to Bruce learned self-defense
and breathing techniques from real-life
resilient jujitsu Grandmaster Rickson
Gracie who gives us the thickest
anatomical
film can't stop looking and Norton
reportedly did a ton of rewrites for
this film adding much of banners
introspection moments unfortunately for
Norton morville is very top-down process
fieger's runs a tight ship and Norton
was later replaced by Mark Ruffalo who
was actually director Louis litt Syria's
original choice for the role
Bruce fixes machinery in a factory a
little foreshadowing therefore how
banner will soon force this guy to get a
new factory and then Bruce bleeds some
outdated CGI blood onto the bottles
below causing his irradiated blood to
make Stanley sick when he takes a swig
of it not the Greek tongue to think
about contaminated blood in the bottle
drinks in your fridge is it now to be
clear ingesting Bruce's game irradiated
blood would not cause lien gesture
himself to Hulk out at would require a
transfusion and probably a family
relation as will be the case for Bruce's
cousin Jennifer Walters in the upcoming
she-hulk series on Disney Plus Bruce's
butchered Portuguese causes him to botch
the classic whole catchphrase
now among cuando yo homie which I love
because the Portuguese word for angry
and hungry or taking it like it's like
he was trying to do this Bruce is mr.
blue confidante since I'm a white flower
for a possible herbal remedy which kind
of evokes the classic flowers scene in
Frankenstein the freak experiment
violent monster that inspired figures
like the whole the failed formula he
makes his bright green and there's a
recurring green color scheme throughout
this film it's like wherever Bruce goes
add green handsome until later we get a
flash of vibrant purple in the serum
stirrings used to try to restrain
banners reaction much like how Bruce
banners purple shorts and the comics
really do the Lord's work in restraining
other things after tracking the
contaminated bottle back to Brazil
Ross assembles a strike team at forts
Johnson named after Kenneth Johnson
creator of the whole TV series and we
meet Tim Roth as Emil Blonsky as he does
in the comics Blonsky transforms into
the abomination but he really is already
an abomination pulling a reverse save
the cat shoot the dog
but hey I guess he doesn't nut check the
dog please pulls a Scott sterling and
Shaw takes a moment here he goes he
fights his work rivals back in the
factory his heart rate monitor beasts
faster and faster the scene uses this as
a kind of ticking clock to heighten the
tension kind of like a bomb about to
explode that first time Bruce Hulk's out
the camerawork leaves him mostly in the
shadows and seen only through green
night vision and our friend teens
pointed out during our discord re-watch
along how the scene focuses more on the
people fleeing him than the Holcomb self
this all cast hulk is a classic horror
movie monster mostly unseen kind of like
the shark and jaws or the xenomorph an
alien in this introduction marks hoax
journey in this film is a transformation
from chaos monster too focused hero and
this thematic arc is also why I think
this movie feels so apart from the rest
of the MCU while some may find it
interesting to see the Hulk is a
terrifying force of nature his marvel
legacy is not meant to be hidden in the
shadows but big grain meant to be seen
so while thematically justified Marvel
later regrind Hulk is a more kinetic
hero in Mexico we get this musical now
[Music]
this is the classic sad music from the
70s series that play whenever David
Banner walked off in the sunset alone
then Ross explains that Blonsky the
background of Bruce's research era that
we've got an infantry weapons
development program while in ww2 they
initiated a subprogram for biotech force
enhancement super soldier and I dusted
it off got him doing serious work again
both work one serum
very please
Ross is referencing the super-soldier
program that created Captain America and
this makes banners MCU origin that of
the Ultimate Comics which links banners
origin with caps and Ross is all about
caps history outside his office there is
a sketch that apparently depicts Captain
America this would be before Chris Evans
was cast in the role in the serum he
pulls out of storage later is labeled
with Stark Industries and the name dr.
Reinstein the alias dr. Erskine used
when he created the Super Soldier Serum
you can also see the term vitae rays
which are the Rays that are Scott used
to dispense that serum into Steve Rogers
now yes it has been a bit of a struggle
to keep these daily doses of distraction
coming at you from the blue dungeon mark
to being stuck inside makes me feel a
bit lethargic sometimes so it helps to
have a pick-me-up
well a big help with waking me up every
day so I can keep this coming at yet is
bang energy thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video every can of bang
is 16 ounces that's right there's no
wimpy 12 ounce cans here it contains
with 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories yet
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from one of those
grape flavors is a Miami Cola even if
your chances of Emma spring break in the
city of Miami are down to nada your
mouth can visit there with just a great
taste of this checkout bag on Instagram
you can get 25% off your order at banc
energy comm when you use the code new
rockstars 25 there you can buy cans at
bang energy including their sweet tea
Kito coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang self
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy comm using the code new
rockstars 25 and follow the inventor of
bang on instagram at bang energy dot CEO
Bruce hides out its family's pizza the
name Stanley is probably a nod to Stan
Lee but also Stanley's played by actor
Paul souls who voiced Bruce Banner in
the sixties animated series along with
several other animated Marvel characters
Bruce snakes on campus giving pizza to
the security guard play by Lou Ferrigno
Hulk actor from the 70 series Ferrigno
and Stanley also cameo Danang Lee Hulk
Bruce also bribes Martin Starr who also
later plays Peter Parker's teacher mr.
Harrington and spider-man homecoming in
part from
and last fear Kevin Feige confirmed that
this computer nerd is actually mr.
Harrington same character adding one
more traumatic event to Harrington's
life hope the pizza was good at least
Ross and Jack's Blonsky with that serum
and he could tell from its alternate
shade of blue that it isn't exactly the
cocktail Steve Rogers got either way
Erskine always said that his serum
amplifies whatever is already in one
soul cap always had a heart of gold
Blonsky always had a hunger for blood
onto the campus battle one of the two
soldiers who fires smoke canisters is a
cameo by John Campea who said he got in
trouble for taking a selfie in costume
and they use Starks sonic cannons Hulk
kicks Blonsky awesome and a few students
record this incident one is Jim Wilson
another sidekick character from the
whole comics friend to Rick Jones who
dies early on the other is Jack McGee
name of the reporter from the 70s TV
series who tries to track down the Hulk
mr. McGee don't make me angry you
wouldn't like me when I'm angry and
their footage later shows up in a report
by whi H the MCM news service that was
later used as promos for later movies
what do you people get your information
huh what kind of news organization is
this oh that's right yeah one that's
owned by Vista Corp and this particular
b-roll of Hulk was shown in Iron Man 2
poke and Betty retreat to a cave where
Hulk yells at clouds this could be
foreshadowing of Hulk's coming conflict
with the god of thunder Thor and some
believe that they could see Thor or
Thor's hammer maybe falling to earth but
there's been debunked that's just the
boulder that hole could just thrown in
anger later Betty brings them some huge
stretchy purple shorts an obvious nod to
the ones Hulk wears in the comics I'll
take my chances Bruce and Betty try to
have sex but Bruce has to slow down this
week's episode of the big question goes
super deep into Hulk sexual history
you're gonna want to check it out Ross's
people track down mr. blue using shields
server the shield logo shows up on the
computer screen and that mr. blue turns
out to be dr. Samuel Sterns played by
Tim Blake Nelson amazing character actor
who plays Looking Glass on HBO's
Watchmen in the comics Stearns becomes
the big villain the leader known for his
big head in Sion ik powers this movie
later hints at that by showing some of
banners blood dripped down into his open
head wound Gazeta bulge out a bit as a
big smile forms on his face the MCU has
never again they've done anything with
Stern's but a few years
Feige did admit to that deep was a bit
of a wasted opportunity the idea that
he's still around has come up but he
just remains locked up somewhere as his
abomination Stearns dialysis process
nearly works for Bruce but Bruce is
taken captive and Blonsky makes Therns
inject him with more of Bruce's book the
mixture could be an abomination like oh
but I a stained subtle ironmonger
wordplay from Iron Man clearly marvel at
the stage was hesitant to embrace the
comic book names abomination rampages
through Harlem they shot this in Toronto
but they redecorated it with harlem's
Apollo Theater but you can still see
some of the Toronto landmarks and
Michael K Williams has a brief cameo
watching this rampage from above Bruce
decides to embrace his Hulk identity to
stop abomination and give him Betty a
smooch and committing suicide now I know
this jump is a bit goofy and I did enjoy
how it was parodied in Ragnarok butthe
matically Bruce's fall is a directional
inverse of the rise we saw from Tony
Stark in the third act of Iron Man Stark
was a morally clouded dude who rises to
his better self to confront the demon
banner by contrast starts the film with
a nice guy who when we break in the
third act must descended to the trenches
to embrace his inner demon directing
that chaos monster into the focused hero
no not control it but I don't know maybe
Amy Hulk and abomination Duke it out
abomination spits out a tooth Hulk will
call this back when taking the
Hulkbuster beating an age of Ultron
domination uses his elbow spike to stab
Hulk's chest Marvel designers actually
kept that scar visible on Hulk's chest
all the way through Ragnarok Hulk
thunderclaps to extinguish the
helicopter fire to say Betty and Ross
one of our first episodes of the big
question did a math to point out how for
hoax a clap hard enough to extinguish
flames he would have to create a sonic
boom that would cause Betty to at least
choke on blood fun episode check it out
Hulk also does another classic range
attack
one detail I love about this it's one of
the few moments that Hulk talks in these
early films and as always he refers to
himself as Hulk now it sets up this
recurring trend throughout the series
that Hulk hates being called Bruce or
banner he insists on being his own
identity separate from banner so
whenever people call him Bruce Banner
while in hole form he flips out
[Music]
you're Bruce Banner right don't mention
puny banner
hey batter no banner only home however
when people call Hulk Hulk or big guy he
cooperates and Hulk smash oh stop just
for once in your life don't slash hope
defeats abomination and exiles to
British Columbia where he tracks down
Betty's pawn necklace the package is
addressed to David be for David Banner
the no homo name from the 70 series and
it's from Milburn pawnshop Brad Milburn
was one of film set designers and his
final shot mirrors our first look at
Bruce once again meditating but now the
goal of that focus is not to restrain
the chaos monster but to release it as
the focused hero and it's a subtle way
of setting up that big reveal and
Avengers that's my secret
amazing now that moment is iconic
because it makes Hulk active big green
meant to be seen
he's kinetic not the potential energy
unlocked via meditation
kudos to Norton for his efforts to
humanize Hulk but really he's always
been more useful to them see you when
they just let him smash the movies post
credits scene actually plays before the
credits Ross is met in a bar by Tony
Stark
but that super soldier program was put
on ice for a reason I've always felt
that hardware
Starks words here referring to cap the
super soldier literally put on ice and
by pitching hardware is more the place
Stark is foreshadowing his conflicts
with cap and the Avengers big man in a
suit of armor take that off what are you
everything special about you me my love
bottle so even though banner is off the
grid it's a bit weird for Stark to have
this conversation with Ross but I like
to think of it as a reminder that Ross
remains the overlooked contribution of
this movie to them to you a super
soldier obsessed blood freak desperate
for a rage monster that he is in control
of an obsession that I think will lead
him to see the red now reminder that you
can join these infinity Saga watch
alongs twice a week with us on discord
by becoming a patron of new rock stars
at patreon.com slash new rock stars our
watch along for aaron man 2 was under
way with a video breakdown coming out on
the channel very soon
comment down below follow me Eddie hey
Boston following new rock stars in
subscribing to rock stars to break down
to everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]